*megalovania brought to you by a skull.*
Do do doot doot doot doot dooot do do do (repeated)
Meme Review everybody! *YAY!*
Guess what time it is...?
Spooky gang x6
My....(?)
calcium is off the chain.
*long live calcium*
Uh, no.
*Spooky boi chanting*
Smash like on this video right now if you drink milk! (like no matter what)
That's right!
This video is sponsored by 'milk.'
Thank you milk, *clap* for sponsoring, *clap* this, *clap*, video.
Milk will...
has calcium in it!
It's October! Spooktober, yeah!
Where the fRiCk are all the spooky memes, guys?
LeTs jUsT JuMp iNtO iT *voicecracks*
When CVS runs out of calcium pills:
rATTLeD *yikes*
If you see this image while watching meme review, *doot doot*
You have been visited by the
Clapping perudral- pervi- (Poods cannot speak) peruvian flute skeleton!
Good bones, and calcium will come to you!
But only if you comment down below...
Gracias Señor Esqueleto!
Hey, hey guys
Remember this kid?
Hm? You still think, you're not convinced of our sponsor?
YOU THINK CALCIUM IS FOR SUCKERS?!
This is him after just one glass of milk.
Imagine what 10 glasses of milk will do
Don't even imagine it; your head might explode
her: come over
him: no, I'm too spooked, it's spooktober
her: I have calcium
*more spooky voicecracks*
*pewds regretting life decisions*
have you ever experienced calcium
symptoms include
intense feeling of BONE
I can feel my BOOOONES!!
look at my boney body
*more regretting of life decisions*
you can also win an iPod 2
alright? that's a great deal
aaaaaAAaa
bones in urine, have you tried it
stop judging if you haven't tried it
I'm so sick of all you prejudiced commenters being
*high-pitched voice*
Stftfffktkfktfkkkk!
what are you gonna do, drink soy?
like a little soy boy
oooo soy boy alert
soy boy alert
this guy doesn't drink calcium, he drinks soy
pathetic
today's video is sponsored by mr. skeltal
thank you mr. skeltal for sponsoring this video
literally no one else will, but he reached out
his... helping hand
and it feels good
what a lot of people don't realize is calcium is metal
*doesn't know where he's going*
you got it
rest in spaghetti Pompeii never forgetti
that's right if you drink calcium your body will be preserved forever
how awesome is that?
smash like if you think that's awesome
whom'st are you and why-
oh right so
a lot people have been asking me
Felix, how did the universe get created?
well here you go
whom'st are you and why
mask you acquire calcium ion
milk element, such as this, is rare
commodity friend
I would- it would be unwise to challenge me
witness the potential
*SUCC*
obsorb
and thus meme was created
remember there was time when the internet before memes
*no we don't pewds*
this is how it looked like
nestle low fat
gimme that full fat milk thank you very much
damn
he is....
slurp
ah let's roll
zero damage clink clink clink clink
zero damage zero damage zero damage
ZERO DAMAGE
haha aww yeyass
drink milk everybody, sponsored by milk, check out the referral link down below
I get $200 for everyone that signs up for my milk class
getting your calcium from drinking milk
meh
getting your calcium from taking a multivitamin
oh ok
getting calcium by just straight up eating chalk
getting all of your calcium by upvoting this video
that's right everybody that's what that said
*clap* *Doot*
calcium meme gets a
rattled everybody
how long is this meme gonna last?
it's almost like we can't even last through October for spooktober memes
they're already dead
undead memes are literally dying
that's how bad this is
the fact that no one has made a meme out of memes dying
is beyond me
cause that's the situation
we killed spooktober and calcium memes in one week
nice- nice work
*small clap*
now some people
have been judging... *clapping intensifies* meme review
this is not fair
just because I review the memes and explain the joke to a large audience of people
doesn't mean I've ruined the joke okay? (It does)
*sans agrees*
alright, Felix, we need more spooky memes
I gotchu fam
dOn't yOu wORRY
"barnacle boy"
*autistic fornite dance*
*uh I mean lit*
*okay now this is epic*
I frickin love SANS!!! (Rule 34 artist, do your thing)
sans memes is what's going to save Spooktober of course
of course, of course, my horse (?)
hey Chris you think it's safe to drink from a fire hose?
Why not dad it's just water. Alright well turn that on I'm very thirsty
oof big rip
IT'S SANS
SANZZ
He's the Jesus of October
*monkey noises*
ok basically
tHAT wAs EPIc
everyone please relax
I think you're going to like this surprise guest
it's snazz, it's gonna be snazz
*disrespects skeleton man*
skirt
I'm so sick of these hAters!!1!
we have an announcement to mAkE
sTtaahp-
Dude, how do you feel- *little doot*
Why is it a meme to just play a song for half a second? Not even half a second
*stuff*
*video gets demonitized for shooting*
thank god! you made the
right choice honey
PLOT TWIST
ppfft***888
snazz is such an epic guy
wAIT!
who are you?
He's Snazz, snazz
*epic spooky music*
hEhahhehHAWH
aw it's so bad but it's still funny
*regretting life choices*
it doesn't get better than dis
the shadow temple
the melody that will draw you into the infinite darkness
that absorbs even time
*spooky Zelda music*
oH! oH!
cmon can we get a full version?
*snazzy music*
*disappointed*
why is family guy and sans a megalovania meme....
out of all things that could become a meme...
snazz memes gets a:
youtube's show, sponsored by Peruvian
Next meme everybody
what meme is he going to kill next?
*laughs at his own joke* (same)
is like this show is just a
an execution at this point
who's he gonna kill next?
all the memes are just sitting there sweating right now
be liek "o pleaze"
ah god
"please not me, i've only had two dayz!"
iT DOESNT MATTER!! *clap*
when you tell a slightly offensive joke at the dinner table
*aheh*
ahEh*
*mEhe*
wHy does printers
always need fricken
mAGentA?
it makes meh so angry
I think i might gonna drop a diss track on magenta
it's in black and white all right I gotchu
and since it's black and white you don't
need any colors to print it right? that
makes sense to me. then rent it
why it doesn't make any sense
what's up with printers?
amirite?
like why do they need
mAGENta?
which is a colour,
AHHA
AHH
*demonic screeching intensifies*
deez nuts
fricken I hate you magenta
s t u p i d  m a g e n t a
whY
do they need magenta
to print b&w?
that doesn't make any sense
*asks for likes*
fricken why like I wanna know
the science
I wanna watch like a 30 minute
vsauce video (???) outta this
michael, vsauce here
do you need colours to print the black and white
photo?
in black. magenta! here take your stupid
magenta! gimme CYAN!
nO
I didn't know this had a skin on it
that's epic
that makes sense
nOw,  we have this new technology
thanks to our sponsor,
calcium, and-
milk
uh where we can see how
a meme is going to last!
let's roll the wheel!
*his life has deteriorated to the point where he's spinning imaginary wheels in front of cameras for money*
11 minutes!
that's a new record
*claP* congratulations magenta meme!
nimininminmimini
always, there's always
these pessimistic son of a guns
that just wants
to trash a meme for some reason
aw but it's my fault for some reason that memes are dying when it's just pessimistic
*loading*
people that think they're smarter than everyone else
for saying err rufd7ififugefuiefg7iFDS
*audio of the ultimate battle royale*
and please consider sel- buying a meme review merch
*clap clap*
I think you guys are really gonna like it
It's probably the most effective way to support the channel and I appreciate it
it's the official meme review merch
designed by yours truly. we have it in
blue without the back print. we also have
a cheaper t-shirt version, and of course
the hat of the intellectual. if you want
to prove your power level to the public
this is what you wear. (Please be patient, I'm 9 years old.)  my name is
PewDiePie and you've just been memed in
*awesome spoooooky outro*